どうも天才料理研究科江田和作です皆さん
はすき家という高級レストラン知ってます
でしょうかすいません高級レストランなの
でひょっとしたら一般の皆さんは行った
ことがないかもしれませんがすき家という
高級レストラン店がありますまあ主に
ビーフを扱ったメニューを中心に展開して
いるんですけれどもそんなすき家で実は
ですね裏メニューがありましてその裏
メニューの名前
キング牛丼
キング牛丼という裏メニューがあるんです
よ皆さん出ましたでしょうか僕も一応美食
家として
キング牛丼何度か食べたことがあるんです
けれども
うまい
時間との勝負でもありました
おっとここで目がしっかりと見開いて
バグっていきます
ただ全然食えたいですね問題ないと思っ
たらまたバグってしまいましたもう眼球
開いてますね
クソ多いくそ多いんです量がちょっと
食べれないぐらいの量のキング牛丼という
メニューがあるんですよそんなキング牛丼
のお値段なんと高級レストランにしては
驚きの筋肉1,140円とてもチープなお
値段でお腹が爆発するぐらいの量食べれる
もう最高のレストラン好きやっていうのが
あるんですけれどもその
キング牛丼
少ない
少なくはない少なくはないんですけれども
キング牛丼の
満足度あれ本当になんかお腹空いてる時
見るとすごい幸せになりまして今回皆さん
にご紹介してるレシピそんなキング牛丼
遥かに上回る最強の巨大牛丼レシピ
theキングオブマジェスティー
黄金超絶1万円エンペラー牛丼作っていき
たいと思います
[拍手]
早速
キングオブジェスティー
黄金郷
超絶一番エンペラー牛丼作っていきたいと
思いますまずは材料の紹介牛肉のバラ5
キロ
今から作る牛丼ですね
キング牛丼の
です10
倍の量です
夏で僕結構の最近お腹空いてるんで多分
余裕でくれます
すいません無理ですすき家の牛丼玉ねぎ
ほどよく入っています玉ねぎ10個ぐらい
準備しましたそして
牛丼のタレ10本お水が2250ml5個
目6kg僕が自分で米を炊いてしまうと
おいしくなりすぎるのでさすがにあの作っ
とあの
めんどかったので頼みましたこれだけあれ
ば皆さんのご家庭でもキングママシティ
黄金郷超絶エンペラー牛丼作りますはい
じゃあ早速作っていきましょう
最初玉ねぎを切りましょう最初玉ねぎを
切りましょうこれだけの量があればねまず
洗わなきゃまずは水洗いしながら皮むき
ますこれわかるのよまずこの目を落とすと
正解です
まな板ないところで
ここも切りますよねはいで
剥きますこうですね正解ですこれぐらいで
いいかな
これぐらいでいいですこれを10個やって
いきます
[音楽]
えらいえらいこの緑色すぎるところ大丈夫
なのこれ大丈夫でしょ
やべえいて
ダメなんです
匂いが嫌いなんだよかわいそうにどの切り
ます全部
剥き終わりました
牛丼に入ってる感じの玉ねぎに切っていき
ます次いきます
これをもってして
[音楽]
死んだでは玉ねぎをそれ相応のサイズに
切っていきますで切ったらもう容器に入れ
ていきましょう
[音楽]
いきます
さすがに分かりますよ牛丼に入ってる感じ
にしろってことこんな感じどうこういうの
入ってそうですね
[音楽]
くし切りってやつですね
どうやって半分に切ってえっとまず半分に
切って半分に切ります切り口を下にしてで
切り口を下にして
斜めにこうわかります
斜めにこう分かりますこういう感じ
1個ずつやったほうがいいかもしれない
です1個ずつやった方がいいかもしれない
ですね
切っていきます
牛丼に入ってるっぽいぞこれこうだ絶対
こうだこういう感じだこれをどんどん容器
に入れてきます
[音楽]
ねダメです
はい
玉ねぎ全部切り終わりました
ちょっと待ってこんなきついんだね1玉と
か2玉とかならわかるんですけど割と
ゼッタムとか言ったことなかったなという
わけで玉ねぎ10玉切りましたこんな感じ
です食器めっちゃでかいんですけども結構
な量の玉ねぎが入りました
次が次が
牛丼のタレと水を中に入れます
焼肉のタレを入れていきます
[音楽]
好きなの味完全再現はできないと思うん
ですけど
牛丼のタレとか使うとマジで美味しい牛丼
にはなるのでこれでクオリ
ティが勝つと思いますでも入れていきます
ちゃんと
美味しそうになるんだ
ちょぼちょぼ
[音楽]
はい10本
牛丼のたれ入れ終わりましたここに水を
足していきます2250ml
約2リットルです1リットル
2リットル
OK250ですこれでちょっと混ぜてみ
ますいい感じのタレの濃度にはなってる
はずでこれを熱して
沸騰させるでこれで捻ってちょっと煮込み
ます
来たか
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいはい気が
通っておりますこれでちょっと沸騰するの
待ちましょう
はい15分ぐらい経過しましたご覧
ください
沸騰してきてますこれで玉ねぎにも火が
通ってるはずなのでここに
牛肉を入れていきます
ありがたいことにすでに切ってあるので
このままぶっこみます行きますはねてき
たらこれ暑そうだなぁいきます
危ないあでもいい感じどんどん入れていく
よこんだけ長いと跳ね返ってこないか
いいねお肉5kg入れ終わりました
すっごいこれであとはお肉に火を通しつつ
焼肉のタレがお肉に染み込むまでって感じ
ですよね
待ってめちゃめちゃいい匂いするよこれ
すき焼きやだよなこれ
タレの量とかもこれ完璧か
完璧だねこれ
[音楽]
マジでやばいガチできつい結構赤いところ
減ってきます
そんなに暑くなかったお肉が冷たかった
からか多分中のねタレが生ぬるくなってる
死んだと思った普通に
[音楽]
はいピンク緩いところがなくなったので
結構いい感じではないかなと思います
玉ねぎにもお肉にも牛丼のタレが染み込ん
でいるのではないかと思います
[音楽]
やばい
これ持ってきます
銃の部分完成しましたではこの大きな要件
にお米6kg分入れていきたいと思います
入れますね
これ多分そのまま行くわ行きます
[音楽]
来た
OK全部入った全部入ったきれいに盛り
たいのでちょっと整いますどっちがいいん
だろうあのカレーみたいにハーフ&ハウス
にするか上バーンみたいな
ちょっと待って
ごめん
完了しましたこれに
牛丼乗せていきたいと思いますじゃあ入れ
ますね入れます
[音楽]
[拍手]
行きますほら
汁がすごいがお肉怖いお肉来たやばい
[笑い]
[音楽]
はいというわけで完成しましたじゃあ
キングオブマジェスティー黄金卿超絶
イチモンエンペラー牛丼です
[拍手]
でかいでかいしもう重くて動かないのよ
ちょっと大きく見えるように高額のカメラ
で撮ってます
詳細見ていきましょう送料約11kg
カロリー約2万3000キロカロリー大き
さはすき家の裏メニュー
キング牛丼の10倍になります
[拍手]
一人で食うぞとりあえずこのお肉自分で
牛丼なんて初めて作ったからお肉の味が
ちょっと気になりますね味見でちょっと
いただきます
[音楽]
ちょっと食べてみてほしいですか
いただきます
[音楽]
あの
吉野家みたいな本当にちょっとねすき家と
いうより吉野家に近い
牛丼になりましたんでいやうまいすごい
これ
[音楽]
ちょっと僕頑張って一人で食べたいと思い
ますちょっと待っててください頑張って
全部食べていきたいと思いますまずはね
普通に並みぐらいの大きさでさ食べたいよ
ねまずは
[音楽]
牛丼並みぐらい取ったんですけど何も
変わりません何とっても全く量が変わら
ないという衝撃の物量それがザ
キングオブマジェスティ
黄金郷超絶モンエンペラー牛丼です早速お
米と合わせて食べてみたいと思います
いただきます
さあ
うまい牛肉がちょっとミルキーに感じると
いうかちょっと優しい味わいの牛丼になっ
てます
[音楽]
素晴らしい
感動ですもうちゃんとお家でもこんな
おいしい自分を作れるんだと
牛丼ファンからしてすごい感動しました
これはもうねペロッと食べちゃいます余裕
でどんどん行きましょうごちそうさまでし
た
[音楽]
まだ食べれるんですけど多分次の一杯食べ
たら絶対もう終わりなのよさすがにね
キング牛丼10杯分一人では食べれないと
思いますがこんなおいしいというのみんな
で食べるしかないでしょ早速みんなを呼ん
で一緒に食べたいと思います
[拍手]